you know i'm gonna intro it again
because for some reason streaming out
lags for like the first 10 seconds so
we'll just we'll just give it like five
more seconds no yo you know what's crazy
yeah i was gonna wear a white shirt as
well
subhanallah bro
no all right let's go
bump it let let me put on a white shirt
dom you got a white shirt as well bro
yeah i got a white shirt
i'm playing
all right let's begin assalamu alaikum
welcome back to the three muslims
podcast podcast in the dunya we got here
brother dom from california dom how are
you doing bro
okay how you doing
good man so rami and anha you're
probably wondering who brother dam is
and so are probably a lot of the viewers
what they don't know is dom
just became muslim about two days ago
tom how do you feel now
i feel great i feel um
like i was telling you the other day i
just feel like a whole lot more like
warmer
uh just like i'm a lot more
uh confident in my future in my
relationship with a lot
and i'm just ready to start this new
journey and see where it take me let's
go mashallah bro so just to quickly give
a recap to the viewers right i get a dm
from you and but guys by the way me romi
and angel we've been doing this youtube
thing for almost two years now so you
know we get dms from people that are
interested in islam they have questions
we do our best to answer these questions
hit us up on instagram at the three
muslims however however however i've
never gotten a dm as sincerely or maybe
at least it's been a while as i've
gotten from don he was very sincere dumb
without kind of going too much into it
do you want to give me a little bit for
the viewers into why you dm me in the
first place and what the intention was
uh yeah i've just been like kind of like
a dark spot uh
for a while now i've just been wanting
to escape some vices
and uh just looking for
something to bring my attention to uh
looking for the truth really and uh you
guys have been giving it to me so
mashallah sounds good bro habibi but
i want you to go a little bit more into
details and and before we go really you
know too much into your story i remember
you know you were talking about some of
the things in your past we can go into
some of the things that you're
comfortable with again you don't have to
share anything you don't want to share
um because once you know we did the
shahada i remember that i was asking you
that you know when we talk about the
next steps into like okay what do we do
now you know because remember once we
became muslim that's not it right it
doesn't stop there it's the first step
in the ladder but it's a ladder right so
we got to keep climbing and do our best
but once we do it now there's a lot of
things we got to learn like how to pray
how to fast you know the names of allah
all these things and i thought why not
we do it with us you know ram is a
little specialist in that mashallah he
can go over some of the basics and uh
you know i think that it'll be more
beneficial that a lot more people get to
tune into that and that's why i ask you
if you don't mind us you know doing this
on a stream and you were down with it
bro you said it's an intention to help
people out so that's what we're gonna do
so let's rewind a little bit um tell us
about your journey with god you were
born christian and
you know where you even ended up being
curious about islam
so
uh i was like always raised christian
like straight from birth uh my dad he uh
just rose me and my brother up in you
know the christian church uh so just you
know grew up learning all the bible
stories that kind of thing
and
i guess like when you're a kid
like
you always have kind of like that
natural like
curiosity or like wanting to question
things you think
says i've always had that natural light
will you know why is this this way why
is that that way why is you know
this how it is and so like whenever i
was
getting into the bible i'd always you
know just question every little bit and
like as i was kind of like questioning
myself and like really i guess
questioning god it was like a lot of it
just didn't make sense to me i guess it
did in some aspects but like when you
compare it to like um like what you got
like with
uh you guys have been telling me and
stuff um
it just makes a whole lot more sense
everything clicks everything is like
almost crystal clear
so uh
a few years ago
um
i read
i think it was like
10th grade i was right before i left
school
um
our english teacher he had us read
uh
the autobiography of malcolm x and
that's where i first learned about like
islam and the nation of islam and stuff
and then i started learning about you
know like the nation of islam's kind of
harmful ideologies and that kind of
thing so uh i started like looking more
on to just more islam as the as a basic
religion as a whole
and like i just really agreed like
with what they were saying uh like i was
telling uh fayad
like the the respect uh like on god is
just amazing like
you come to america like a country uh
predominantly built on you know
christian values christian wars that
kind of thing it's like those morals
they they disappear
it's uh you know over the past few years
it's like this country has just gone
down going down going down strong
swiveling away from
what we're supposed to be believing but
then like i was telling them uh you go
to the middle east
everyone's still you know doing the
thing everyone's following
and doing what they're supposed to be
doing what he says right there in the
book nobody's trying to change any rules
or say oh well you know
that society nowadays you know that
that's what it is it's okay now you know
it's a different time nah
god made these rules for a reason you
guys follow that to a team there's just
always been respect on what god said and
what god's word is and i think that's
really the right way to go it's not what
we feel should be right and wrong and
what god said was
wrong or whatever it's what he said
where he goes and you guys follow that
um
so that's the part that really made it
like click like
why like
why are christians like trying to like
change stuff you hear me and it's like
so it's like
that's another thing that like led me
into is like researching the bible it's
like there's so there's been so much
that has changed
like even just looking into like the
apocalypse the apocryphal books like the
like the missing books of the bible and
things like that the things like you
know the catholics were moved and you
know said
you shouldn't be part of the word or
whatever it's like you never even know
what the true
word was like you know what god really
said and it's been translated in
uh misconstrued so many times over it's
like we don't even know what we're
reading at this point
um
that's fox bro i agree angel bro you you
came from
christianity as well so catholicism so
you know do you agree with some of the
things was your journey kind of similar
yeah
yeah and i don't know if you had this
experience done but
anytime that you had a question about
something and you asked let's say the
pastor
or anyone else that was a christian or
just a believer right
they said
it's it's like they will almost condemn
you for asking questions
yeah now i remember uh one time because
i was specifically uh it was like when i
first started looking into islam i had
asked
like a preacher about it and he told me
uh like oh i shouldn't i shouldn't think
that way and that uh islam was a
dangerous religion because they believe
um that you can get to
heaven based on deeds rather than
believing in jesus and like when he said
that like
i'm thinking in my head like that
doesn't make any sense at all i said i
get i go to heaven based off
just believing in something rather than
how i acted and how i was as a person
that doesn't make any type of sense at
all
yeah
bro it's crazy too that in islam like
the more you get into it the more you
see
it's not even your deeds
that gets you into heaven it's
it's ultimately like
allah is god well it's
that's what decides if you're gonna get
to heaven or not you're good bro you
could be the best person in this world
you do everything perfectly
and then allah could still
send you to hell i think that was um
please romney jump in if if i'm gonna
butcher this i'm gonna try my best insha
allah
this
i'm like i should be known as the dude
who's just like butchering every single
story and all that stuff
nah nah
but bro so this is one story um
[Music]
this um one companion
right
and he
i think it was like
he had basically he passed and you know
he's he asks uh actually bro romney
please go ahead now i'm gonna butcher
the hell out of this so
it's the one where their companion is
ass like oh if um i did all these good
deeds like allah like i don't want to go
to jannah based on your mercy i just i
want you to go i want to go to jannah
based on my good deeds
like
so yeah i don't remember the full story
but i remember kind of like the crux of
it
so
i don't know how it led up to the point
but basically the prophet peace be upon
him he told the companions that nobody
gets to heaven on account of their good
deeds you know in and of themselves
and the companions were like not even
you like not even the prophet of god not
even the messenger of allah
he's like not even me
no one gets to heaven by their own deeds
except
by the mercy of allah so what our good
deeds and our intentions do is they
basically prove to us because allah
already knows but it proves to us and
it's displayed for us to show that based
on these things allah is going to grant
us his mercy because something like
jannah is not something that you can
work towards not something that can be
you know like christians like to argue
against them bought with good deeds it's
not bought with good deeds it's
basically showing that we've done more
good than evil in our life or we've been
forgiven from by allah and we have such
good intentions that allah is looking at
this person saying this servant of mine
deserves my mercy you know and actually
maybe we could talk about it later but
the the the term
the most merciful actually has a very
specific meaning when it comes to mercy
do you guys want to talk about it now or
do you want to hold it for later no we
can we can hold it till the until a
little later because we do want to go
back to the story but i want you to
finish your point too rami
the story
okay all right
let's go back to it but dom so so carry
on with your story bro i know i know the
viewers are just they're just edging bro
all right so
yeah i started uh looking into
uh islam and stuff like that uh just
really looking for truth um
at the same time i'm like
heavily dealing with um
you know seeing um
mainly just uh
pornography sex
uh that was just my my advice uh just
constantly running back to that and
um
that was just like my hook i just need i
always needed to be having you know a
girl with me
or you know my phone i'm it's either or
i can't i can't go without one
so
uh it was really like
it's like living in a rat race bro it's
like that's all your mind thinks about
and it is so tiring it's like you want
to
escape from that you want to you want to
do something else with your life but it
just keeps calling you back and keep
calling you back and you don't know
where to go
so it's like that's when i really
started in the past like a couple years
that's when i really started doing like
some soul searching and like really
trying to find god and like reconnect
because it's like i'm really just trying
to escape that uh
that dark place
hmm
god you got you and when you when we got
on that phone call between me and you
that night i remember asking you too i
asked you how long have you been looking
into islam you know and what you told me
it wasn't a recent thing it's been kind
of for a while right it's been a process
um months to even years bro you've been
looking into it and by the way you said
you were 20 now right
yeah yeah bro i was telling you dom on
the phone too i was like i don't know
what it is about being around the age
20. a lot of people that we deal with
that come to us that are looking um
it's like around the ages of 20 and
after the age of 20 you know it's like
something just happens and we all come
back to islam but in those stages in the
last few weeks or months right did you
do anything oh
you pray to god did you did you
you know make dua i thought i taught you
what i meant right from allah
did you do anything like that by
yourself
yeah i've been uh
i've been actually praying a lot more
trying to at least i downloaded like the
app
uh
i think it's kind of like a thon
okay uh with like the prayer times so
i've been trying to
i've been trying to hit those uh since
we talked
i've been trying to hit that i hit a few
of them but um
bro yeah i've been just trying to uh
play on my own
i feel like
i feel like um
i don't know what to really
i guess
talk about because i feel like
i go in so much i guess asking for stuff
i don't know how to like
how to worship like it feels like i'm
just you know needlessly asking asking
asking and it's like i'm what am i
really
doing well i mean asking god actually in
and of itself is is a form of worship
you know and allah he actually he
actually loves when his brethren asks of
him and by extension you can say that
it's not befitting of a servant of allah
not to ask allah for anything right it's
a very beautiful thing so and obviously
there has to be a balance between you
know praising god and asking of god
but there's nothing wrong with asking
god and i don't think
i mean i don't know your life right but
i don't think needlessly asking would be
the right word i don't think it's
needless i think it's probably probably
what you're asking for is very important
or dirty or important to you
um and i think that's very beautiful and
asking allah will never be a bad thing
so long as what you're asking for is
good and if it isn't then god just won't
give it to you but prayers
we know that prayers and salah more
specifically is like
basically the bridge between belief and
disbelief and it's the thing by the way
salah actually
linguistically the word means like
connection to connect that's what salaam
so it's beautiful because you're one on
one you're like connecting with god and
as soon as you establish those you're
gonna have a type of solidarity in your
religion because this is something that
you do every single day five times a day
from the very morning you wake up
to you know the last thing you do before
you sleep at night
that's beautiful bro i was also telling
dom a little bit into the five place but
before we go into that just to sum it up
for the viewers right now that's that's
a lot the likes up on this video um to
recap dom you've been put on
christianity you know you've been
questioning things some things didn't
add up you know you remember the fitra
that i talked about you want to explain
viewers what you remember from what i
told you about the fitrah
yeah it's like our kind of like natural
uh like yearning to connect with god
like it's like our natural consciousness
instead with god yes it's our default
settings you know the programming that
we were put on and and that wants to
seek for god and by the way as a
christian bro did you ever believe that
jesus was god did you ever believe that
so like that that is like another thing
that just really i guess shook me uh
like about christianity because it's
like
uh
how can how can god you know be a man
you feel me it's like so many times uh
jesus you know when he was talking about
god he refers to him you know as god
rather than as you know myself
so what it's like or he would say like
uh my father or uh you know this is my
father's house you know god's house
um
not my house you know so like it's just
weird that they take that dichotomy or a
direction with it uh
to like say that they're
they're one being it's just it just
never made sense to me another thing
that never made sense and like uh like
the holy spirit
when you're telling me about the like
the future um
like bro let me way more sense than like
their concept of like the holy spirit
because like
i guess like the concept of the holy
spirit is supposed to be like almost
like your future like
like that's like your consciousness and
like your connection like to god like
our voice uh with god and kind of you
have that once you
become christian but then it's like if
you're not christian then how do people
know right from wrong still it's like
when you're four years old you know it's
wrong to you know go delete somebody
here right
you you don't have the holy spirit
no that's bad
the fitra is something correct we've all
been you know we have it since we're
born and we we have it all the time you
know in islam actually the holy spirit
we believe to be the angel gabriel bro
jibril islam so gabriel you know the
archangel gabriel who comes and gives
revelations to different messengers and
prophets
right yeah
that's
but christianity took itself as
something almost out of life
itself an equal footing to the trinity
the kind of inferior i don't know bro it
doesn't make sense to me but with all
that being said do you want to kind of
go a little bit more into you know once
we did have that conversation bro um i
remember asking you too i was like bro
are you ready to become muslim you
didn't even hesitate how did you feel
right then
bro i was like excited i just felt it
bubbling up for me and just like uh when
we sat down and did it i was telling you
bro like i just like like how i am now i
just couldn't stop smiling bro i just
had a big grin on my face like i just
felt like warm inside i could feel like
the presence of allah and i just felt
like just happiness just complete joy
it was like like it was like it's like
been something i wouldn't like wanted to
do
because it's like i feel like
i guess i've always known in my heart it
was the right thing to do and it's like
so like once that action was completed
it just broke it felt complete 100 bro
and how did you feel also knowing when i
walked you through the process i was
like bro you don't have to pay any money
right because there's no like shahada
there's no paperwork there's no contract
right how did you feel that you didn't
have to go through and organize
institution or anything like that how
did you feel you could just do it where
you are it's just between you and allah
and you just have to testify one thing
bro it's like almost like a burden off
my shoulders because he's like
to be honest that was like one of the
things i was like uh worried about
because i thought i would have to like
to do something like along those lines
uh
like find like a mosque or something and
it was uh
to be honest is really intimidating
because i i wasn't sure like
for like one where to go um i don't know
you know any uh
people in my city that are muslims so
it's like i wouldn't know anybody going
to the mosque
uh for one and for two it's like i don't
i don't speak arabic so it's like trying
to go there as a just english speaker i
i was just too intimidated so it's like
uh when you mention that like we can
just do it here right now just like oh
cool
that's facts and we did it in english
and arabic right just uh just so you
really internalize we did the
transliteration and the translation i
want to ask a question to brother angel
before we go back to dom on how was your
journey with the shahada itself when you
found out it doesn't have to be
something super formal or organized or
publicized you know how did you find out
knowing it could be done in like 5
seconds 10 seconds with the sincerity
and it's simple
that was beautiful man
you did it for me
remember
yeah we did it together i still remember
bro
yeah
marshall was about a year and a half ago
yeah
and bro since then you know you look at
another you look at brother dumb i make
dua that allah makes it easy for all
these reverts and guys just keep keep
being sincere with your duas me and
brother rami we were kind of born into
islam right but we we found islam later
in our life um but i think it's all the
same bro at the end of the day when you
know you know bro and dumb
that brings me to my next question once
you became muslim you know i was talking
to you about the five pillars a little
bit right so do you wanna you know and
there's no wrong answer here bro you've
only been muslim for two three days why
don't you tell me what you remember
about the five pillars and if you
remember the order of importance
sure so
i have the first ones uh like your
shahada
uh
the second one
i believe uh
was the prayers yes
uh the third
was
um
uh giving the 2.5 percent uh that's
that's the fourth one very close the
third one is something else it's also
once a year
oh uh uh i know it come on
there you go
uh
oh uh fast for ramadan there we go boy
that's it fasting for ramadan number
three number four you said it's the
zakat paying the 2.5
of your
extra excessive saved wealth that is
unused portion every single year once a
year and what is the fifth one bro
i visit mecca visit mecca go to hajj if
you are able to if you can support it
once in your life minimum
and if you can't you can bro but allah
knows best so
to recap it you know i told you a little
bit about the importance and i told you
you know the shahada is the most
important thing right this is something
we have 24 7. now when we talked about
the prayers you know we talked about the
importance of praying you know as
muslims we don't just have to believe we
also have to do good action right but
ultimately once you do good action you
do as much as you can and at the end
it's up to the mercy of allah if we go
to heaven and not right
now you had some questions about prayer
right i remember even before our phone
call that night you dm me you were like
i want to know how to worship allah the
correct way right and i was telling you
on different religions different fates
you have different ways of worshiping
god that they believed to be correct and
true and i remember i made this analogy
to you bro i said dom how do you
as let's say dominic how do you prefer
to be contacted
if i was to ask you
hey just text phone call just text a
phone call right and i asked you bro
what if i fax you
i don't have a fax machine you don't
even have a fax machine bro so it's kind
of counterproductive do you see what i
mean
so wouldn't we want to worship allah
subhanahu wa the way allah subhana wants
to be worshipped or should we decide as
human beings how we want to worship
allah
we gotta follow what allah says and how
he says we should worship of course fair
enough right beautiful so rami why don't
you talk a little bit about salah about
prayer and how we should worship allah
the way allah deserves and needs to be
worshipped not us and when i say need
not in a way that allah needs it but the
only correct valid way
yeah so
i discussed what salah is and what
prayer what is islamically a little
while ago so just to recap quickly salah
is a connection that's what it means to
connect and
this act of worship was something that
allah gave the prophet directly
so everything else came through the
angel gabriel who was mentioned before
every verse from the quran certain
revelation the angel would bring it but
on this
certain occasion uh the prophet peace be
upon him was actually blessed with the
you know this what we call a night
journey where he traveled and then he
actually ascended into the heavens and
this is where he actually spoke to allah
and allah gave him the salah the
connection right
the prayer right then and there one on
one
and this is a little sub no but salah
originally was supposed to be i believe
like praying 50 times a day or something
like that i remember telling him that
yeah yeah and then
musa moses peace be upon him you know
when he came across prophet saws on his
way down
he said listen i've been through this
before your nation is not going to be
able to handle that he was thinking of
you know the children of israel and what
happened to them and what they ended up
doing he's like your people are not
going to handle that go back and ask
allah for a reduction so this happened a
few times until allah reduces the five
he didn't reduce the value of it
so if we pray if we pray five it's as if
we prayed all 50.
subhanallah allah didn't reduce it in
its value but he reduced it in its
number as a mercy for us
so we have five we have fajr which is in
the morning before sunrise we have dohar
which is in the afternoon asura which is
like midday maghrib which is sundown and
asia which is at night these are the
five obligatory prayers allah says pray
at these five times
and this is one of your bare minimum
things you have to do
there's a few other that you mentioned
the five pillars of islam
and then there's the
uh you know enjoining good and
forbidding evil if you believe in allah
and everything he says in the quran you
enjoin good for bid evil you did you do
those those five things that are
obligatory
you will go to jannah that is what we
believe as a muslim these things are
like the bare minimum
where allah will grant you his mercy if
you do them
and there's a very beautiful narration
we call the a hadith
meaning that the prophet he starts by
saying that allah said this
right so the prophet peace be said that
allah the most high had said that the
most beloved acts of worship the ones
that i love the most right give a very
beautiful example of communication right
the acts that allah loves the most are
those which he made obligatory the ones
he says you have to do them
we have to do them and allah loves them
so much so look at that beautiful
connection and then he says and then the
servant my slave my servant continues to
get closer and closer to me
with voluntary act of good you know the
extra prayers that you do or you know
bringing your mom a cake from the bakery
or flowers when you get back to be nice
to her or giving extra in charity all
these good beautiful things that you do
extra allah says that a person does
these things more and more until allah
begins to love them
and then there's the rest of hadith is
beautiful i won't go on from there but
salah is like the pillar of all of that
salah your prayer five daily prayers
is basically what i would say would like
make or break your faith as a muslim it
is the thing that will hold you from
doing evil and it is also the thing that
will encourage you to do more good and
that's why allah has prescribed it now
we can go in depth into the movement and
how they actually have you know
physiological benefits and so on and so
forth
but i think that might be a little too
deep so i'll pass it back to fight
inshallah yeah and definitely bro dumb
we can create like a group chat between
the four of us among us so we you know
rami can definitely send you like a
voicemail or like a video on how to you
know praise allah uh like he's done with
me like he's done when i asked him bro
there's a lot of reason you know you
know you gotta come through i'm sure
he's done the same thing with angel and
you know at the end of the day that's
all we're trying to do it's not anything
you know super difficult bro i told you
it's simple right
but yes and joined good for a bit evil
bro that was a wonderful point and dom
do you want to tell the viewers if you
remember this one thing i told you that
if you have to sin as a muslim what is
one thing you should try to avoid doing
i bringing it like up like uh talking
about it spreading it
yes and doing it in front of other
people right and doing it in public
right we should do our best to limit it
so i already told you bro it's listen
and and i don't want i don't want the
the kawaras after me bro listen as a
muslim right
as a muslim we still sin
and a lot of people seem to forget that
today and they're too harsh
the prophet saw mentioned every son of
adam is a sinner the best of sinners are
those that repent to allah the only one
that can forgive us for our sins so
let's let's stop acting like you know
we're sinless we're perfect we're angels
listen we're all gonna sin
of course we pray to allah to make it
easy that we stop sinning right
but if you have to sin try not to do it
openly right we already talked about it
but
in a step in the process of you doing
these things just like rami said salah
the prayer the worshipping this in and
of itself is a shield from singing and
from evil and from kill right so
remember we need to do these things what
was the second thing i said bro when you
sin what do you follow it up
one more time i said do you remember the
hadith i said
he said that when you sin every time you
sin you followed up
with prayer
with a good deed
ah that's right yeah that's right so if
you have to sin you know follow it up
with a good deed now we can talk a lot
about the good deeds but i want to kind
of take it back to you right now
if you have any questions for now aside
from the prayer which we will mention to
you we will get it sorted out
these could be any questions you have
bro anything like that's always been on
your mind anything you wanted to ask
about islam anything that you're a
little uncertain about
um
to be honest uh really
uh he's just more of looking for uh like
resources
um
so i was gonna ask you guys about uh
recommendations for like uh
i guess books uh i can maybe like go to
for more information uh or like you know
like a devotional of hadees or something
like that
as well as like what uh
uh
translation of the quran you guys
recommend
perfect and rami right before you go on
with with uh your beautiful answer to
some of these questions
i wanted to offer you bro and i'm not
saying this bro public i would have done
this anyway even if we didn't get you
know do the stream but dom send me your
adi bro
and inshallah you can agree with me but
this one that i have right here the
clear quran you know
angel was you know told me a lot about
this and how there's many translations
of the quran because there's there's
different translators but this one one
was the most succinct one it was the
most simple one it was the most
efficient one an effective one so god
willing
but on me bro take it away how can you
seek knowledge
so seeking knowledge is one of the
obligation in islam right so it's one of
the things you have to do so i'm happy
alhamdulillah that you're already on
that that wave so
to seek knowledge i'd say the most
important thing that you can do is
actually find a teacher find someone a
shaykh a leader of a masjid or just a
brother with more knowledge than you who
will teach you not just
you know the the truth of islam and what
you should and shouldn't do and what's
halal and haram but you know teach you
islamic etiquette and mannerisms and all
of that things that the prophet peace be
upon him it really emphasized and
practiced in his life
um you know there were some of the
greatest scholars back you know
when islam was just spreading
um like imam shafi's
these great like giants in islam these
scholars and
you know when they were younger and they
would learn from their teachers one of
them actually went back to his mother
and she asked like what did you learn
and then he was telling her about what
he learned and she was like okay go back
you're not done go back and learn more
and the reason is not because he had a
lack of intellect but it was because he
didn't learn the mannerisms
that come with islam and that's what his
mom realized so
he sent her back so there are books
definitely and we can i'll send you a
few offline insha allah
about you know the seer of the life of
the prophet peace be upon him about
islamic etiquette about
you know the basics of what what you
should and shouldn't do but the basics
of how to pray and the basics of belief
and all these things are beautiful but
i'd say the most important thing
is that you read the quran
just like brother uh had mentioned
this will and it is a translation
uh so you're not going to get the full
exact
you know word for word but you will get
a good understanding of what allah wants
if you read this it's basically as if
allah is talking to you so
read the quran connect with it it will
spiritually enlighten you and insha
allah offline you know what we'll talk
about where to go from there in terms of
resources and stuff i think finding a
teacher it might be a bit of an
unconventional answer but finding a
teacher is one of the most important
things you could do as a muslim
okay
yeah bro and and i just want to be the
first one to say listen
i don't and and i say this perhaps in a
way of you know being grateful for it
like alhamdulillah me and rami might
have had it a bit easier you know maybe
perhaps we look muslim
upon first glance to many people and so
we might not get ostracized but i just
want to you know a moment of of of
reverence and even you know praising a
lot of these reverts that go through
ostracized
right let's say they pull up with
tattoos you know for example you know
the reason i say this because tattoos
are sin in islam right but maybe a lot
of people are emotional and they don't
realize that perhaps this brother wasn't
born muslim perhaps for a muslim there
is no sharia there is no
right so for the non-muslim he perhaps
got these tattoos or all these
spirituals and maybe he he did all these
things unknowingly right and remember
what i told you right when you become
muslim what does allah do with all your
sins
he washes him away exactly all of your
sins are erased right but some of them
throw some of the brothers into they'd
be acting like repentance and
forgiveness isn't a thing so they forget
that sometimes they get a little too
head strong right they might give you
some glances they might give you some
stairs and this does happen to a lot of
reverts right but on this something
about the individuals and the masjid yes
they're valuable because we should pray
together right congregational prayer is
better than praying by yourself however
however the most important thing to
understand is allah has forgiven you bro
so it doesn't matter how you might look
it doesn't matter where you're coming
from it matters where you're headed so
when you go to the masjid it doesn't
matter bro if people are pulling up in
tattoos or whatever you know um a lot of
people think you have to get them
removed no bro you don't have to get
them removed should you now glorify them
and boast about them and talk highly
about them
influence more people to get it no right
that's not what i'm saying but we
shouldn't be embarrassed of going to the
masjid so when you find the masjid near
you right make sure you find the proper
masjid right you don't want to go to an
ahmedi masjid or a nation of islam type
of mosque or anything like that right
just a proper you know
following true islam and when you go to
the masjid bro you know talk to the imam
be like i'm a reaver you know i want to
learn and you can do that stuff but
again one of the first and foremost
things i would recommend is reading the
quran the english translation of the
quran very simple bro very succinct and
i wanted on how to kind of go a little
bit into that because there's some
valuable things that hanha shared with
me about you know how you don't want to
read too much
more than you can handle you want to
take your pace with it so why don't you
uh talk about that
about the the quran or about
the quran
um yeah bro so
first time i read the quran i tried
reading way too much at first
um of course you know like
whatever you're gonna get from me you're
gonna get from it but if you just take
your time with it
um there's no finish line
you know you could take years to finish
the quran it's allah knows that's your
intention
if you're even if you read only like one
sentence
one ayah a day that's perfectly fine
just read that one sentence reflect on
it
and go from there because that if you
spend a day reflecting on this one
sentence it's better than if you read
the entire quran without reflecting on
any of it bro
yeah
and um
you know some days you'll feel like you
can read more so
by all means read more you know
the the key is to not
make it difficult for yourself because
islam is
meant to be easy for you
it's not meant to be difficult for you
all right
yeah
and i mean i don't
we aren't on this topic here but i i
really wanted to say this because it's
on my mind right now and there's some
two things that i wish i would have done
myself when i came into islam number one
is just really take things
as slow as possible
like people are going to try like
getting your contact information giving
you all this stuff to like looking to
read this
um
talk to this person over here watch this
video over here and like look that's
cool now they probably have the best of
intentions
but it's very easy to become overwhelmed
with all the information like bro we
could spend our entire life
studying islam we will never know 100
everything about islam
we will never
they have different fields of study if
you actually choose to go into studying
islam to be like a scholar of islam like
they have different fields of study and
you can spend your entire life and
you might not even finish one field of
the studies
so again take it as slow as you need
and
don't don't rush the process man because
allah he he prefers that we do something
even if it's like this tiny
but consistently every single day
because it brings us
closer to allah brings us closer to uh
just being in that ground that plays
that peace
and then the last thing that i would
recommend to you though that i wish
honestly i wish i wish i wish i wish i
would have done this from the beginning
is keep a notebook
and you know how people journal right
yeah
yeah so keep this notebook
and start journaling your experience as
a muslim day by day
because there are so many different
stages and there are so many different
um
moments of growth that happened that bro
like when i look back i actually
can't recall a lot of them but a lot of
them were really really impactful and
i wish i would have just wrote them down
you know like there's one thing that hit
me a long time ago
where
you know i love to pray right i love
that we do the five prayers and as
fayette as for me as anyone who knows me
questioning like i take my time with the
prayers
and i do this because i feel very
grounded very present and very close to
the creator when i do this
now
this has led me to have moments where i
feel like i'm not sinning but it's like
fire said we are we're all sinners
and if you ever think that you're not
sinning well you're already at fault
because that just means you're not aware
of something that you're doing that is
uh harming yourself or harming someone
else
and something that i realized during the
prayer is like
not even me realizing allah made me
realize like damn like
sometimes i do things
and it's not so i look back on it where
i see like ah i actually harm myself
in this moment i actually did this
person wrong and i didn't even realize
it so
now when i ask allah for forgiveness i
don't just ask for forgiveness of what
i've done but for the things that i'm
not even aware that i did
so that right there that's a realization
that i had that allah made me realize
and of course i remember this one but
there are so many other ones that i had
that i don't remember because i didn't
write it down so
do yourself a favor pick up a notebook
or use your iphone notes and just every
day just kind of like write down
uh i don't know whatever is most like
impactful for you
as a muslim that they go mm-hmm
bro that was deep i wanted to you know
highlight that key point that you
mentioned earlier on
that the prophet saw mentioned the best
of deeds are those that are small
but consistent
so similarly when you do very small
deeds but consistently and you build
yourself up you you do it in steps right
you you do it when you you pace yourself
you don't take on too much more than you
can do
similarly the sins that you're doing
right sometimes we can't quit sins cold
turkey is uh isn't that right on her
and and i don't say this to
undermine our willpower or or or you
know courage and zeal as muslims that's
not what i'm trying to do
but being honest bro you know sometimes
let's say some people are alcoholics but
some people are addicted to things that
they can't just leave overnight and they
might cause more than not think you
should do these things that's not what
i'm thinking what i am saying is
similarly you know you want to leave the
sins you want to pray to allah you want
to make dua to allah to make it easy
right but it's realistically it might
not happen overnight for a lot of people
and that's okay but in islam when it
comes to one thing that you were
mentioning you know
women right that's one thing islam allah
doesn't shame us as men for having
people when i told you that on the phone
do you want to be a little bit into what
you remember me telling you about how in
islam sexuality is not something
yeah yeah you remember bro
yeah
yeah you're saying like um
how uh
like with the
with me it's like it's like part of our
instinct you feel me to like repopulate
and that kind of thing and then uh
you're also explaining like uh
like the situation like with the like
uh wives and that kind of thing
exactly exactly so one thing i did want
to leave you with before we wrap up
to accept and understand that as men and
as women we have desires
therefore the prophet saws
prophet peace be upon him he would
encourage us
o shabab the youth you know get married
as early as you can when you have the
ability to get married now this ability
to come here now i'm involved telling
you the two bro you remember this this
this marriage in the eyes of allah the
institutional marriage is different than
the western marriage you want to you
know tell us something that you remember
me saying
uh that's a lot for example um
let me picture a western marriage you
thinking of like a bill wedding you know
like a hundred people and all these
gifts and the cake and everybody's
suits and all that kind of thing
and like when you're breaking down like
uh
like an islamic marriage it's uh
it's literally just like the union of
two people it doesn't need to be that is
you know
the man asks the father of the the girl
he wants to marry if he's okay
you need a witness provide the gift and
that's it it's really simple
and see the when we
make marriage i want to quickly wrap
this up bro is it's different than the
the western marriage that you were
talking about correct you know people
saving six months of salary on a ring
dropping 400k on a wedding i've seen it
all bro also some mentioned you know the
the lowest you know financially invested
weddings are the best and you know
keep for the intention of unionizing
people like convention right
but i touch on the point that it's not
some big event that makes you nervous or
anything like that it's a very simple
thing is to make two people halal or
one another right and there's nothing
wrong with that so i wanted to not say
hey man now that you're muslim
you can't be looking at these haram
things on your phone and doing you know
haram things with yourself and having
you know promiscuous intimacy with
random girls and i'm not going to just
leave you with that i do want to offer
you the suggestion right that you know
once you you know spend a little bit of
time you know a few months which is
understanding the basics as a muslim bro
and you feel confident as a muslim right
understand that marriage isn't some huge
you know
pristine thing that they portrayed as in
the media in the movies in hollywood
right in in islam can you have a book
yes it's the sunnah sunnah is something
we should do emulating the prophet saws
right so you know it's not something we
can't do of course you can have good
night
right you can invite people you can have
a celebration right
but
the marriage itself is separate from the
wedding the marriage itself we call it
h right and this is a ceremony you just
do between two people and it's it's
simple bro and i invite you to uh when
you feel ready bro definitely just look
into marriage grow and get it done bro
i'm just letting you know you know you
know it's not something with like you
know christianity you want to devote to
god and be a priest or anything you
can't have intimacy it's nothing like
that bro
all right
any other questions bro any any last
minute things you want to ask
um
at this point i can't even think of
anything
but like you guys are so
informative
so good at what you guys are doing
bro may allah make us as he feels wrong
well listen it's it's we're flawed bro
we're sinners and and it's the coolness
of your eyes let's see us
as what you mentioned us to be bro but
guys smash the like button if you made
it this far for more streams like this
make dua for brother don and all of
those that are either reverts
or a couple months into the reversion or
they're even not reverted yet they're
thinking about reverting and accepting
islam migdawa that allah makes it easy
for them
and don bro
after you became muslim
if you were talking to someone let's say
or even your your old soul
what would you tell them if you could
give them one word of advice or to
anyone right now that's considering
accepting islam
bro just uh follow that natural feature
bro if you if you feel that like feeling
in your heart uh that there's no
something more and that you need to come
to
a lot just follow that and
you're going to feel the truth and
you're going to feel the power that
allah has
martial
that's amazing bro
all right guys
let us know what you guys thought about
this stream in the comments down below
smash the like button rami
we are definitely going to make a
four-man group chat with brother dom
should be very easy because he has an
iphone 2 so we don't need to make
whatsapp bro i don't know why but
whatsapp just seems so much more work
than than android than an imessage but
you know you got brother angel over here
who's using what's up a lot lately so i
don't know bro we'll see
but why don't you do your thing bro
all right inshaallah
uh before we do end off there was one
more thing that i talked about earlier
uh sure
i don't know maybe it's an ocd thing i
feel like i need to make i don't know
bro do it
so
allah begins
in the name of allah the most greatest
and most merciful
i want to talk about that that point of
raheem
because it ties into what we're talking
about before
raheem is the one who gives his mercy to
people who specifically go out of their
way to see it
so
um
is basically the one who gives everyone
mercy
just because you know they're his
creation for example allah gives
everyone water the ability to to breathe
air on this earth and and eat and feel
contentment and feel you know happy once
in a while or maybe even most of their
lives
that's allah being a roch man she's
granting it
because it's his creation you know
living in this test of this world
but
special raheem is you you get this
special mercy because you go out of your
way to work for it
and i think that's something that's
really important for us to remember in
life that as muslims we're not entitled
to anything and that to achieve the
mercy from allah and that jannah even
insha allah we have to seek out
the one who gives
special mercy to those who seek it out
and that being said
this